well there is a theory David about what
dark matter is you talk about different
universes let's say that our universe is
a sheet of paper we live our entire life
on this sheet of paper but directly
above us
there could be a parallel universe
hovering right over us
perhaps inches centimeters away and
objects in this parallel universe would
be invisible light travels beneath the
universe so we never see this other
galaxy but gravity gravity goes between
universes because gravity is nothing but
the bending of space so if the space
between two sheets of paper is bent
slightly gravity then moves across so
think about it this other galaxy in
another universe would be invisible yet
it would have mass that's exactly what
dark matter is dark matter is massive it
has gravity but it's invisible it has no
interactions with light or the
electromagnetic force so there is a
theory that says that perhaps dark
matter is nothing but matter ordinary
matter in another dimension hovering
right above us we should also point out
however that there are other theories
too dark matter is the cutting edge of
science some people think that maybe
it's a higher vibration of the string
all the atoms of our body represent the
lowest octave of a tiny rubber band
vibrating all over our body and the
rubber band can have a higher octave
that next octave could be dark matter so
that's yet another explanation for what
dark matter might be so the bottom line
is this there's a shelf full of Nobel
Prizes waiting for you waiting for
anyone who can come up with a convincing
and experimentally verified explanation
of the origin of dark matter
you